[Music]
hey
it's us again here man last night
[ __ ] damn that show
that was fun well man it was like we
were only 10 or 15 minutes in and you
were already talking about your balls
[Laughter]
so it just went spiraling down i don't
know
i just you know depend on how the show
starts you know what i mean [ __ ] i'll
get into it quick it might take me a
little while
to warm up sometimes but other times
i'll just [ __ ]
just go right off the bottom just right
into it
but did you see did you see that um
because remember how we were talking
about like on the show about like um
the people that lick the insides of the
ice cream containers yeah and how you
should you should like take their
toothbrush and like rub it all up in
your ass and stuff
yeah and then somebody commented on the
youtube channel like somebody
actually did do something like that
except it was like bad guys doing it to
innocent people so it was kind of like
apparently i don't know the exact case
but apparently somebody broke into these
people's house while they were gone
and took some pictures on their camera
of himself
basically sticking the woman's
toothbrush
up his butt damn and they didn't know
because they didn't get the pictures
developed until later
or they didn't look at the pictures
until later
so i'm like well that makes me never
want to brush my teeth again yeah well
somebody breaks into your house make
sure to throw all your [ __ ]
toothbrushes yeah it's like that's scary
because that's like not something that
you would think of
yeah but they were [ __ ] with your
toothbrush toothbrushes are cheap
so you know yeah
just gotta make sure oracle says that
all that [ __ ] went down because tom just
[ __ ] uh says whatever comes out of
his mouth
that's true you do yeah it kind of it's
kind of like channeling an evil spirit
or something
yeah that's like it's like a ouija board
just like a [ __ ] comes out it's like all
kind of evil people yeah
crowding around in there yeah i don't
know what it was you know we didn't have
that much to drink really
last night but man i [ __ ] woke up
early my stomach was killing me it's
because i was uh
i had that damn i was it was all that
lemonade spiked lemonade
yeah the acid really got to me yeah he
woke up like so many times last night
and ever and that wakes me up too
because he's always like moaning and
groaning
i had to drink some damn arm and hammer
baking soda with water
and then you were over there like
burping and stuff burping it all up
yeah plus i thought i was gonna i
thought i was maybe going to throw up
just because of all the acid you know i
mean
throw up in it you throw up kind of like
the alien from [ __ ] the xenomorph you
know where it just
eats through these through the toilet
yeah you know what it is man when you
get older you're just
stomach acid gets to you well i yeah
it's like i'm
you know i've always kind of had like
you know uh
stomach problems digestive issues and
stuff ever since i was a kid
but it's definitely gotten worse as i've
gotten older and it's like now
i can't even like i can't eat raw onions
anymore even though i used to love them
like on burgers and stuff can't eat that
anymore otherwise i will have like
heartburn for two days and it's getting
to a point where
i have to really be careful with like
tomato sauce like if you have like
spaghetti sauce or pizza sauce or
anything like that because that will
like
have me hating it's got to be i heard
that there's something for that there's
like some stomach
fauna that you can eat like tablets that
rejuvenate your stomach enzymes yeah i
think there's some [ __ ] you can like
yeah there's pills you can take like
before you eat before you know you're
gonna eat something i gotta
cause the problems yeah somebody knows
what stops that you know what i mean
i heard it's yeah beezness says orange
juice gives me bad reflux yeah yeah me
too sometimes not always but
i heard it's because when you're older
your your your defenses start
killing off your own stomach fauna yeah
and therefore you can't digest as well
so you got to constantly replenish it
eat stuff that has
bacteria in it you know like yogurts and
stuff yeah you see some of that
but evidently there's like some really
good [ __ ] you could buy in pill form but
i don't know the details i just heard
that yeah it was like an advertisement
yeah it may not be true which yeah they
they're just probably gonna lie
like they're telling you that you can
eat collagen and it'll make you younger
you can't eat collagen that's [ __ ]
well that's the thing it's like a lot of
things that that's yeah exactly
that's that's not how that works but
yeah so all right so you want to talk
about a movie
yeah we might not be out too long
because i just ate some pizza which was
probably a bad idea but yeah
you can't get around it man everything i
cook [ __ ] [ __ ] you up
[Laughter]
so i'm saying we gotta get some more
toms yeah yeah well cause i sit there
and i was like can't i just eat food
like a normal person without feeling
like crap
afterwards that would be really nice if
i could do that but i don't
i've hardly ever been able to though so
uh as i mentioned
last night i was very excited that i had
this idea i was like for the matinees
this week because i want to do like a
whole halloween week extravaganza
i said for the matinees we should do
like all newer halloween adjacent movies
and uh to that end i went through 2b and
shutter and
netflix and everything like that looking
for some
you know past five years like halloween
theme type of movie so that's what we're
going to be talking about
so the first one we're going to be
talking about is a little movie from
2016
and it's on to be and it's called lost
creek
now this is obviously um i believe the
the director's name is colin adams
toomey and i think this is his first
movie i don't know if he's made another
one since then
um it's clearly low budget but
not in a way that it's like doesn't look
cheap actually the cinematography is
really nice and stuff like that
it kind of reminded me of it's like it's
about this little boy
named peter and he moves to i don't
think he moves to a whole new town or
he didn't move that far i guess because
he still had a friend
that was at another school or something
like that so i feel like he moves
like the next town over like his mom has
gotten divorced or some
[ __ ] and so the kid
moves to town and he goes down by this
creek
and he meets this little girl who's
about his age and they're like come
become best friends and everything
but then it turns out that there
is like all these rumors around town
that there is
a ghost and or a monster in this town
that the kids end up having to fight
yeah so it's already kind of setting up
a situation like it
or uh yeah stephen king type
yeah you know i'll just say
off the bat you know i know you guys
looking expect me to [ __ ] on it quick
you know if i don't like it actually
this one was pretty good
it was pretty good i actually kind of
enjoyed it it really got me like in the
halloween
it's a low budget movie this is about
the best you could do with the budget
like you're talking about although i
must say the end
scene how how the monsters defeated was
a little bit anticlimactic
but it was kind of unique in a way
yeah but they were i think they were
constrained you know the budget
you know they couldn't have a bunch of
special effects yeah
so you know i'm not gonna spoil it
yeah i don't wanna spoil too much about
it because this is i feel like
if you're into like movies from because
i don't know if this movie was set in
the 80s was it i didn't i don't remember
anything i don't remember anybody having
a cell phone or anything did they
i wasn't really like paying attention
the cars weren't too out of date though
from what i remember
that's true they look like 90s cars 2
000 cars
yeah i couldn't really tell what year it
was supposed to be um it doesn't really
matter
yeah but um yeah so this little kid like
you know moves to the town and then it's
but it's a very um it reminded me a
little bit of like it was kind of like a
steven spielberg
kind of vibe but kind of like stranger
things kind of kubrick
it is slightly there was some kubrickian
shot composition in certain scenes
yeah the cinematography was actually
quite nice um like i said it was very
halloween it's very orange and it's very
little like really it's like you know
little pumpkins on the
stretches and the strength of the movie
was the acting
it's a it's most of the cast are kids
but the acting is pretty good
the main character's friend is the
[ __ ] riot i love that kid
dude it's funny it kind of felt kind of
felt
like a spielberg type comedy with a
bunch of kids you know
spiel kids in spielberg movies you know
always say funny [ __ ]
yeah that's shit's going on through the
whole movie yeah so
um kind of liking from close encounters
the kids and close encounters the kids
and poltergeist
they were kind of like that yeah look at
people back there what you're doing poop
you're gonna chew on the power cables
like i don't
[Laughter]
she's i don't know why she's always
chewing on that yeah but yeah one thing
i was gonna say like one movie that this
reminded me of i don't know if you guys
remember it or not
this the vibe of this reminded me a
little bit of the lady in white which i
think came out in 1988
in the sense that it's not like a horror
horror type of movie like it's kind of
like
subdued but it's the same kind of vibe
where it's kind of like a creepy
like ghost story it's more like
atmospheric but it's not like super gory
or anything like that like kids could
probably watch it this seemed like a
good
this seems like a good movie for you
know kids that want like something
that's kind of creepy like little kids
that want to watch something that's
kind of creepy but is not like gory or
horrifying or anything
because like all the main characters are
kids and um
it seems like real relatable i was gonna
say interestingly what the hell are you
doing
she wants a child on a lamp okay she
just chews on everything she's like a
little goat
but um i was gonna say that the kid
actors are actually like
the acting's a little amateurish but not
in a not in an annoying way they're
actually kind of endearing
you know what i mean if you know what
i'm saying yeah it doesn't matter that
it's amateurish
yeah if it still kind of fits the tone
of the movie
yeah which uh you know i and i don't
think there's not like a huge amount of
like surprises in it
um because there's one character in
particular that you're going to be like
that you're going to call it yeah i
called it like yeah an adult sees
through
in the first couple scenes an adult can
watch the movie
you know what i mean uh but like but an
adult sees through a lot of
plot devices although there were some
twists i didn't see coming but yeah i
didn't really know how it was going to
end yeah
i mean just that one thing i kind of
called but like and if you see the movie
you'll see this would be a good one for
kids i mean
[ __ ] it's it's it's like the tone is
kind of like poltergeist
yeah but nowhere near as it's not as
scary not nowhere near as scary as
poultry guys like it doesn't have the
actual dead bodies in it and [ __ ]
[ __ ] coming through it doesn't really
have that
because culture guys had actual dead
bodies and you didn't know that
[Laughter]
they snuck that [ __ ] by even the actors
well yeah that's because
you know the actors would have been
upset of you yeah okay we're gonna put
some like rub some
like dead bodies up against your face
yeah they'd be like yeah no i actually
but um yeah so like i said this would
make a good companion piece and i'm glad
some other people have seen
lady and white um this kind of reminded
me of that like the vibe of it
so if you have little kids that want to
watch something that's like
halloweeny and is like a horror movie
but it's not super super scary
this does have like some creepy moments
in it like i particularly like the
scenes where the main character
um peter is like sleepwalking
and somebody's like going down in his um
you know kitchen and like the [ __ ]
pantry door opens and it's like
the scenes at the end with the monster
um that looks pretty cool like i like
the
the look of that um but it's not
anything that would like
traumatize a little kid you know what i
mean business says all he has is netflix
tell you something b's net b for the
extra five dollars a month man just go
ahead and get a [ __ ] shutter
i think shutter is better than netflix
but netflix is good because it has some
classic series like star trek
and they do come out with some good
movies you know
but dollar for dollar man the way to go
is shutter
and what what shutter running them up
it's either i can't remember it's 475 or
5.99 it's one of those just can't be but
like i said i pay for it uh yearly
right right you pay for it all at once i
paid and i think it was fifty nine
dollars for a whole year that's right
um and i just you can do monthly
you can yeah you think it's like eight
dollars i think it's a couple dollars
more
if you pay for it monthly i think no
it's not it's the same i think it's 5.99
okay
all right but um well the reason that i
went to yearly was because i was doing
it month to month
um and they were like hey if you go to a
yearly subscription then you get like
the free shirt
so i got that but i was gonna say that
they have a new shirt coming out
um fright rags is doing it and it's
really really cool i pre-ordered one but
it's not coming out until november
um because i think it was only 20 bucks
like and i really
wanted it so i decided to get that
because my other one is like
getting kind of old and faded yeah so
she's in the house
yeah i didn't get any notifications she
just guessed the time
well like i said it's what ended up
happening was we were
you know we were supposed to go on at
three like normal and then
tom didn't realize what time it was so
he was like making a pizza and i'm like
we're not gonna have time to like cook
the pizza and eat it like before three
o'clock
um but then like by the time we ate it
and stuff it was only a few minutes
after three
so i was like okay well we'll just go on
even though i had announced that it
would be like 3 30 or 4.
um because it didn't take as long to eat
it as i guess yeah i guess it would
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] everybody's backing me up
what i said about shutter mega was in
there and [ __ ] hernandez
and they're saying yeah for the money
that's the way to go when you think
about it 4.99
that's what we spend on a single b-movie
rental over xboxes 4.99
yeah and yeah so i dropped that couple
times a month just to do the reviews
so for the price of one b-movie rental
you can see
everything that's on shutter and it's
just all horror and sci-fi
actually is there sci-fi there's only
there's sci-fi horror on it
yeah but there isn't just pure sci-fi on
it i mean there's kind of like they do
horror sci-fi thrillers that type of
stuff
i mean it is pretty horror-centric yeah
and they do have shutter exclusives they
got some
a lot of new [ __ ] but they also have a
lot of the old classics
and they're like in blu-ray quality they
look good i like that they
all remastered they just added a whole
bunch of the um the roger corman edgar
allen poe adaptations which is really
exciting because the hammer films is
just
titty fast like [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
yeah that was england man back in the
60s they're gonna put her
they're gonna put hot girls in there
from all over europe germans and italian
girls you know what i mean it's like
just all in [ __ ]
just cleavage down blouse the movie
that's what i told you
and then like uh all the classics
you know what i mean uh well what else
is on there jenny [ __ ] every
everything yeah it's like there's a
whole bunch of classics there's a whole
bunch of like new stuff
if if any movie gets like any kind of
play at any kind of festival
um recently they'll generally get their
hands on it
um and they have like a bunch of really
cool like weird
like cult classics and stuff too because
they actually have like a bunch of
people and some of them are kind of
famous that are like filmmakers and
stuff
all the old zombie movies all the
italians yeah they got a bunch of lucio
folgi on there i think they got some
dario agenda they got some other uh gela
movies
on there too like stuff like switches
out yeah but like i said between shutter
and tubie
which is free um you can see most of
anything like you that you want to see
yeah
tummy is good because it has everything
on there including the junk
yeah you have to know what you're
looking for like i said
it's free to be free if the the thing
with duncan
shutter though is that it's curated yeah
if it's on
shutter then it's worth watching then
it's usually worth watching they don't
put anything in there it's [ __ ]
they don't put anything crappy on there
i mean like like i said you know
it's gonna be a thing where some people
aren't gonna like certain movies i get
that because they do kind of put some
arty stuff on there they have some
foreign ones that are kind of like you
know
mandy's on there yeah [ __ ] like that a
lot of space is on there yeah they just
put color out of space on there the
other day yeah
um but but they don't put anything like
i said to be
good but you have to know what you're
looking for because toby has like 40
bajillion
horror inside movies and a lot of them
are just kind of like you know asylum
level or
some asylum level so it's like you
really got to watch because you don't
know what you're getting
but like i said if you know what you're
looking for because this movie lost
creek
um is i found it on 2b as well
and this was actually a good flick it's
low budget but it doesn't
look like cheap it doesn't look like a
cheap low budget movie and it looked
like it was really well put together
and you know they actually put some
thought into it and into the script and
everything like that
and it had like really likable
characters a really cool like halloweeny
type of atmosphere it's like you know
it's a perfectly great [ __ ] movie
yeah you know
yeah i thought you were gonna say
something else no
no there's not more to say about it i
don't think yeah it's what it is what it
is
it's it's it's a low-budget movie it's
it's pretty well executed
it's for all audiences but without being
corny you know sometimes it's some of
that moving for all
audiences it can get kind of corny it's
not like that it's got a decent tone
kind of
spielbergy and type of tone yeah and
like i said if you have
you know little kids or like you know
maybe pre-teens
that are looking for some i don't know
about pre-teens but maybe like little
kids
it'll still trip them out but it won't
[ __ ] scare them yeah it won't like
traumatize them or anything because it's
still like kind of creepy and it's you
know stuff like that but it's not like
terrifying or gory and i don't even
think there's like
a lot of swearing in it or anything no i
don't think there was any not that i
remember
yeah but um it just had a really nice
atmosphere i just it just put me in like
a halloweeny type of mood which
is what i wanted out of all this and
this is why i decided to do this for the
matinee this week
so we actually have um i have three more
planned we've already watched one of
them i'm not gonna say what it is um and
then we have a couple more that we got
to watch sophie says she's on team
amazon prime
she says you can she can get pretty much
everything off amazon that's what i've
heard i probably should probably look
into getting that as well i mean you
know between
like i said between netflix shutter 2b
we can usually get what we want to get
i mean and then every now and then like
we can just like do a one-off rental on
xbox like on the microsoft store or
whatever
um i don't think we've had too much
trouble finding
stuff every now and then if i want to
see something that's like kind of weird
or like hard to get a hold of then you
might have to like
have other problems but i want to get
behind shutter i think i i could
actually give up pretty much all of our
streaming
services except shutter if it wasn't for
the [ __ ] good series the series
that sometimes appear on [ __ ] netflix
i like it i like the fact that all the
old star trek is on
yeah we've been rewatching i watched
star trek yeah like because well they're
very comforting because we've seen them
a few times but it's like
and i like star trek enterprise yeah
archer and [ __ ] a lot of people didn't
like that series i love that series
yeah yeah a lot of the next generation
people are oh man that's the worst one
that destroyed
actually no man i mean season one was
kind of rough but about halfway through
season two it started to get really
good because it took a while for the for
them to kind of get a direction
you know yeah they had one of two of the
best mirror episodes ever
out of all the star trek any mirror
darkly wanted to that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
really good
but i liked it yeah you know to paul and
[ __ ] you know
looking archer i like honestly that
they had jeffrey collins playing general
schrandt yeah that's amanda
that's right yeah he was talking about
that on or yesterday the other day
dorian [ __ ] commander it's pretty
good i feel like he was getting drunker
and drunker on that interview
he wasn't like it was like really we've
got to have jeffrey combs
on the show and gets get starts getting
sentimental doesn't want the show to end
that
[Laughter]
he's adorable i love [ __ ] jeffrey
well i think he's not into social media
he didn't know
i don't think really what what to expect
from a youtube show
and you know back in the old the old
school days you know everything was
a crunch for time what [ __ ] time slot
you were on on television
they were just real superficial and a
guy like jeffrey combs never really got
any attention in the mainstream media
yeah he's much very much more he's just
too an occult figure
so that's perfect for [ __ ] youtube
yeah because you can just go you can
just waffle on as well for hours and
hours
like we do and the dudes that were
interviewing him had
relics from the movies like one dude had
the resonator the real resonator he yeah
he got it from europe after you know
shipped in from europe
and combs was [ __ ] amazed that the
dude who was talking to him
over over the over youtube had the
[ __ ] resonator yeah the actual
one from the movie yeah the actual one
for the movie in his living room
i can't remember that guy's name but
i've seen him on other like horror
documentaries because he's like
one of the big like horror collectors
and he's got like all kind of cool combs
was tripping that this dude was spending
[ __ ] thousands and thousands of
dollars to collect
jeffrey comes memorabilia i mean you
gotta think that's like kind of touching
[ __ ] from the [ __ ]
[ __ ] from the shows and you know and uh
he went on about the frighteners which
is
like i said man [ __ ] he did what was
his name uh agent danvers i think is
what his name was
i thought that was a [ __ ] great role
i liked that movie the tone of that
movie was [ __ ] fantastic
and there's two edits i saw the
theatrical edit in theater i liked
it but on the blu-ray they have the
they have the director's cut it has a
lot more in it
yeah it's longer yeah it's better i like
the director's cut
i feel like that's like a movie peter
jackson made that they don't like that
kind of doesn't get a lot of love you
know the timing was weird
it's a strange movie but it's you know
what i mean just tonally it's a strange
movie i can see why people were kind of
like meh but it's like you know
it was like back to the future but kind
of a horror movie in a way yeah
a dark horror movie it it it's like a
dark comedy it had comedy in it too
and it was kind of like it was kind of
like uh
what's his name mcfly gone bad yeah you
know what i mean
marty mcfly but he's kind of gone bad
yeah you know bad [ __ ] happened to him
and he [ __ ] could now see ghosts and
stuff and uh just
i just thought that was a great movie
but i remember when it came out i saw it
just by pure chance
i was coming home from work and saw
saw the saw that on a billboard as i was
driving the car and i said yeah
i want to see a movie and i just said
frighteners and it said michael j fox
this is
i haven't seen a michael j fox movie in
a while i just saw it just by pure
chance i didn't even know jeffrey
coleman's gonna be in it
and uh back and i was like the only
person in the theater
yeah and well you know theater was kind
of dead i guess
at that time but um
people were kind of sick they were
spoiled in those days for
high quality movies and with good
writing that [ __ ] was
there was a lot of that then so in some
ways
it was kind of samey for its time i
think
people just you know i i mentioned it
some people oh you see frighteners in
there like ah
they're like that you know yeah yeah
kids
are already here [ __ ] yeah they were
like sick of it
they were like sick of movies
i was sick they were sick of movies
that's that same old [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well hey they didn't go see it that's
true you know
but you know it's classic i feel like it
got like a cult following it yeah
though yes but yeah so like i said this
movie it's on to be for free if you want
to go watch it
um i kinda wanna like like i said i like
to kind of get behind
indie filmmakers that do this kind of
[ __ ] because
and i feel like nobody i don't think i
saw any other review of this on youtube
so we might be the only one
i saw some like um some written reviews
like from different festivals and stuff
like back from when it came out
but i didn't see any like video reviews
so i guess this will be like the first
one
but yeah like i said good uh double
feature with the lady in white if you're
into that in that kind of vibe but it
really it really did
like put me in a halloween type of mood
which i'm very excited about
so yeah we're going to be talking about
another newer halloween movie tomorrow
that is kind of um
a little bit of a different vibe than
this one i'm not going to
i'm actually more i'm actually more um
jacked for
um [ __ ] christmas chronicles too well
everybody's everybody's yeah
yeah i want to see christmas chronicles
too well we might do this that you know
what we might do the same [ __ ] like
maybe the month of december we can just
like try to do christmas movies
we can find that many good christmas
movies i don't really know but
christmas chronicles one man's become a
[ __ ] modern
[ __ ] christmas classic evidently
people said
every daily people are watching that
like every christmas now i could see
that like i said
i think it should go into the yearly
rotation yeah
because it's just a it's a fun it's fun
putting it on for the kids every [ __ ]
day
every week for chris for christmas yeah
it's a fun movie like i said it's just
kind of like every christmas i always
watch like the mst
3k christmas episodes because that's
just something i do
i heard and i feel like they should add
that i'll add this to the rotation
i heard that christmas chronicles is
like one of their big main heavy hitters
on [ __ ] netflix
people saw but i haven't seen the data
but
evidently it was [ __ ] amazingly
popular
and [ __ ] christmas chronicle too man
coming out with goldie's in it
mrs i hope she has like a bigger part
this time around yeah it looks like
she's going looks like because she was
only in it she only had like a cameo
last
time and i felt like i was like oh that
would be so cute if she was like in the
movie like the whole thing
sophie said she just watched tb
halloween last night she said i thought
it was kind of cute and heartwarming
tv halloween hubie qb halloween the one
with adam sandler oh yeah yeah
yeah he doesn't remember
not that you said tv no hugh b remember
yeah it was all right
yeah i had it i had a good time it was
it was absolutely it was amusing
adam sandler being silly i still i still
say
[ __ ] uncut jams much better [ __ ]
adam sandler movie
well like i said he can act when he
wants to and he's been in other movies
like that where he's like it's where
he's like a serious actor and he's
actually a really good actor
uncut jams just adam sandler's good
fellas
yeah that movie like gave me anxiety
through the whole thing which it was
kind of supposed to
supposedly so
what kind of crazy [ __ ] is he doing with
other people's money
[Laughter]
but yeah all right so uh we'll be back
again tomorrow
at uh probably around 3 p.m talking
about another newer halloween movie
uh but in the meantime check out this
one it's on to be for free like i said
it's called lost creek
and we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow bye